عندما نتحدث عن صناعه التمر يتحول التركيز
فورا الى مخاطر التدخين على صحه الناس
والصناعه واحده من اكبر الملوثات في
العالم ولا يزال التدخين سببا رئيسيا
للوفيات التي يمكن تجنبها حسب ما ورد في
تقرير جديد لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
وذكرت المنظمه ان 4 دول فقط هي البرازيل
وموريشوس وهولندا وتركيا تطبق كل
الاجراءات الموصى بها لمكافحه ما وصفتها
باافه التدخين الفتاكه
لدينا بالفعل دولتان تقودان مكافحه التبغ
في العالم وهما موريشيوس ومملكته هولندا
لذا يسمح لي ان اهنئ كلا البلدين على هذا
الانجاز فاول دوله افريقيه واول دوله غنيه
تحقق الانجاز التاريخي المتمثله في تطبيق
الحزمه كامله لاجراءات مكافحه التبغي على
مستوى افضل الممارسات وهو انجاز لم تحققه
سوى دولتين اخريين حتى الان وهما البرازيل
وتركيا
وتهدف الاجراءات الموصى بها من قبل
المنظمه الدوليه للحد من استهلاك التبغ
الى خفض عدد الاصابات بالسرطان والامراض
القلبيه ومشكلات الجهاز التنفسي التي تحدث
جميعها نتيجه للتدخين
وحطت منظمه الصحه العالميه الدولي على
توسيع نطاق استخدامها لهذه الاجراءات بما
في ذلك فرض حظر على الاعلانات ووضع
تنبيهات صحيه على عبوات السجائر وزياده
الضرائب على التبغ وتقديم المساعده لاولئك
الذين يريدون الاقلاع عن التدخين
وانتقلت المنظمه بعض الدول لعدم اتخاذها
مزيدا من الاجراءات للحد من استخدام الطبخ
لا يزال نحو مليارين وثلاثمائه مليون في
44 دوله غير محميين باي تدابير لمكافحه
التبغ مما يعرضهم لخطر العبء الصحي
والاقتصادي لتعاطي تبغ كما ان ثلاثه
وخمسين بلدا لم تحضر التدخين في مرافق
الرعايه الصحيه بشكل كامل وهذا امر غير
مقبول على الاطلاق
وفقا للتقرير فان واحدا 71% من سكان
العالم يعيشون في دول تطبق اجراءا واحدا
على الاقل لمكافحه الطبخ ومع ذلك يبقى
التدخين سببا رئيسيا لوفاه نحو تسعه
ملايين شخص سنويا
بينهم مليون و300 الف يموتون بسبب التعرض
للتدخين السلبي معظمهم في الدول منخفضه
الدخل او متوسطه كما ندد التقرير بعدم
وجود تدابير لمكافحه السجائر الالكترونيه
في اكثر من 70 دوله تضم ثلث سكان العالم
وتصطدم الجهود الوطنيه والدوليه لحمايه
الناس من اضرار هذه المنتجات بصناعه قويه
وواسعه الحيله تستمر في النمو من حيث
الربح والتاثير